so hi everyone my name is Shawn and I
recently finished my master studies in
tel-aviv University and today I will be
talking about my thesis which was done
under the supervision of professors
David Amanda witch and Roger Davis with
the funding of remote in Tel Aviv
University and the subject is like
should be focusing based on sparse and
other information so I will start with a
short introduction about like food
photography so regular cameras only
record the total amount of light that
intersect with each pixel on the sensor
and therefore they get on the spatial
information of a scene light would like
in Taurus record the direction and
intensity of each light ray that
intersects with the sensor and therefore
they get spatial information and angular
information of the same thing and a
single light field image can be
represented by 40 10 zone and we can
look at it as a series of RGB images
that are arranged on a rectangular grid
and each one of them is taken from a
side slightly different angle this is an
example of a five by five angular
resolution and each one of these images
has a spatial resolution of M by n by
tree because this is a color image and
the spatial coordinates are x and y each
one of these images is called a sub
operatory image so light field can be
captured by light row camera this is a
camera with a micro lens array and it
captures the multiple light rays oh
sorry it has two major drawbacks one
it's a little bit clumsy it's about this
size and second one there is a spatial
angular trade-off resolution and I will
talk about it in a couple of slides so
what is right with god far the most well
known application is depth estimation
this is an example of a depth map which
can either be use for face recognition
adjuster commission and so on there are
several applications for the medical
field the material recognition and the
application which I was working on was
post capture refocusing so the annual
information enables us to change the
focus plane after we capture the image
so after we already took the image we
can generate a series of images and each
one is focuses on a different object
okay so this equation looks a little bit
scary I will just explain it basically
to get a refocused image we need to take
each one of the sub Apertura images that
I showed earlier and shift it by a
factor which is better mind by two
factors one of them is alpha the focus
factor and it tells us on which object
we want to focus and it is the same
factor for each one of the images and
the second one is the location this
specific celebratory image on their grid
because an image in this location will
not be moved like an image in this
location and then we some of the 50
images and we divide by the number of
them the problem with this equation is
that is continuous and we have first a
discrete number of sub Apertura images
so we will have to have as many images
as possible in order for the results to
look continuous to our eyes and this
means high angular information a
resolution the problem with this one is
that in life in the images a life in
cameras there is a trade-off between
spatial and angular information there is
only one sensor and it captures both of
them so if we increase the spatial the
angular resolution we will pay for it
with spatial resolution so this is our
motivation to be able to perform light
with applications based on sparse
angular data only and then we can
increase the spatial information
resolution in each one so let's talk
about our metal we took four sub
arbitrary images which considers very
sparse and we generated one refocused
image at each
so we first check what happens when we
try to refocus an image using the basic
algorithm we talked about before
remember that I said it has to be
continuous and as many as some aperture
images so we took it via we moved it we
shifted it and we summed them and
dividing by four and the results were
bad you can really see the ghosting
artifacts near the tree and the leaves
over here
and note that when we increase the
angular resolution it looks a lot better
and we increase it to 17 by 17 views the
artifacts are almost gone and it looks
more smooth and continuous so we want to
get this result using this data and how
do we do it by convolutional neural
networks so we took these four images we
shifted them according to the focus
photo and we inserted them to a neural
network we first had to generate the
ground flow so what we did was to take
we had a light field of 17 by 17 images
to each data image we only took 241
images of them these are the blue images
to appear as close as can be to a shape
of the aperture of the camera which is
circular the red views are the four
input views to the network and so we
took this 241 bills and use the basic
equation to get 1/3 focused image for
each data for each data point okay this
is the network architecture it also a
little scary this is a fully
convolutional network with two
trajectories the first trajectory goes
through convolutions of 3x3 and when you
I mean each one of these outputs go buy
another convolution of treachery and
those residual images are summed to one
sum of residuals and to this we add the
average of the sub opportunies which
talked about in the beginning to
preserve the areas in the image that we
want to preserve and the sum of visitors
it corrects the artifact
so results these are the results of
clean data you can see that the networks
correct the artifact and the results of
you are very much close to the ground
truth images these are two different
focal points for your focus point we
also trained a network or noisy data
using noise augmentation so the network
now hit two missions it had to refocus
the image and clean the noise and also
you can see that the results are very
good also if use metric of psnr or ssaem
you can see the change in numbers who is
familiar with this metric and that's it
we talked about refocusing algorithm
with that can performance parts the data
their performance is new real-time it
point zero to twenty two seconds on a
GPU it has low memory consumption and it
opens the door for developing lights and
cameras with lower angular resolution
and spatial angular resolution in return
and
[Applause]